so we now have lo and behold what a
surprise we have audio with subtitles of
the confrontation between Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren that happened on
stage at the end of Tuesday night's
Democratic presidential debate there is
so much to say about this I showed the
video to you yesterday and we are
showing it again now of this moment
after the debate during which Bernie
denied having told Elizabeth Warren that
a woman can't be President and Elizabeth
Warren completely ignoring that reacting
to how she felt when Bernie told her
that day that a woman cannot be
President so at the end of the debate
Elizabeth Warren went over to Bernie
Bernie extended his hand for a handshake
Warren refused to shake it and said
something which led to a brief
confrontation before Bernie kinda did a
forget it sign and then walked away we
now have a version with audio and
subtitles telling us exactly what was
said and I want to divide the analysis
into two parts and then we're moving the
hell on from this okay first is the
content and then is the context because
both deserve some discussion here to
start with let's look at the 16 seconds
in question that took place right after
the debate now with audio and subtitles
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not do it right now you wanna have
that discussion we'll have that
discussion you called me and you told me
all right let's not good okay okay so
Elizabeth Warren accuses Bernie of
calling her an AI a liar on national TV
Bernie says will you called me a liar
and then quickly says let's not do this
right now we can do this at some other
point and then walks away so before we
move on to the serious stuff by the way
fanboy Tom Steyer saying hey Bernie just
saying hi and Bernie's reaction of yeah
good okay is is hilarious it's like a
kid awkwardly asking about having a
cookie while mom and dad are arguing
with each other but let's get on to the
analysis let's first analyze the content
if we assume that everybody is acting in
good faith first of all and then we'll
get to that we've been trying to figure
out Bernie says he didn't say it Warren
says he did say it it's hard to a
imagine that Bernie's belief is women
can't be President so maybe there was
something more that explains the whole
thing so at its face if you ask me
what's the most likely scenario if we
assume everyone's acting in good faith
and hold that for a second we'll get
back to that the most likely scenario is
the reason why they both say the other
is lying is that both Bernie and Warren
believe that they remember it going
different ways
Bernie believes he didn't say it and
Warren believes that she did say it or
they have totally different
understandings of what the context was
neither one of them likely remembers the
word for word of what was said this was
well over a year ago at this point they
have different understandings of what
was meant or implied it doesn't change
that it's a fabricated controversy that
only helps Joe Biden it seems to have
been crafted by CNN but that's at least
an explanation as to if they both are in
good faith saying you're lying no no
you're lying
the most likely scenario is they don't
exactly remember they have different
interpretations of the context and both
believe that they are telling the truth
here's where it starts to get slippery
for me and this is where we have to add
in the context and other things that we
know Warren knew that she was miked up
at this point when this took place on
stage every politician knows that when
the show ends and it's been 15 seconds
and you're still wearing a mic and the
room is filled with cameras you operate
as if you are being recorded
and she was being recorded and she chose
to do this while miked in front of a
camera two seconds after the debate the
cloud the crowd is still clapping Warren
is front and center she confronts Bernie
Sanders she knows exactly what she's
doing while bernie is going in for a
handshake he seems genuinely surprised
that she's doing this onstage and says
let's discuss it later so for me it's
every indication that any disagreement
about what was actually said is being
handled in the most public way possible
by Elizabeth Warren which suggests or at
least makes me question whether this was
a crafted and coordinated campaign
between the Warren campaign and CNN by
the way here's a clip of CNN's Erin
Burnett actually saying the Warren
pane leaked to this to CNN take a look
Warren had no problem with this story
yesterday it was clearly leaked by her
team to CNN it was it came out more than
a year after the meeting it came out on
the eve of a debate this is pretty clear
she knew about this she she sanctioned
it everything around it indicates that
why is she pumping the brakes now
indicating don't want to talk about this
anymore we're all cool because this is
probably the last thing she wants to
talk to Iowans about before they vote so
then a couple of thoughts on the outcome
because that's really what matters here
first of all it's irresponsible not to
mention the context okay there is no
chance in hell that the conversation was
an isolated statement by Bernie where
Bernie said women can't win the
presidency and Warren says I think a
woman can win and that's the full
conversation nobody clarifies anything
does Bernie mean women cannot be
president in some kind of base way which
seems inconceivable does he mean sexism
and trumpets and twenty20 would make it
tough for a woman to win which is a
reasonable opinion to have you could
agree disagree but okay and that being
said you know Warren when this was
brought up during the the debate on
Tuesday Warren said that she knows her
friend Bernie Bernie is her friend if
she knows him the way she claims to she
should be saying hold on a second based
on my long friendship with Bernie he
would never suggest women cannot do the
job of President they that they cannot
win an election this was a
misunderstanding about strategy strategy
but Bernie is not a sexist and she
hasn't done that which is another sign
that the Warren campaign is
participating in this if this ends up
being a Biden Warren ticket like if
Biden ends up being the nominee and
selects Elizabeth Warren as his running
mate
I think circumstantially it would throw
more fuel on the fire that makes us
question what coordination went into
this but the more important thing here
is this doesn't seem to be helping
Elizabeth Warren it's also not likely to
help Bernie Sanders much either as I
said before the entire narrative fills
corporate media with other stuff it
takes attention off of Joe Biden
offering basically a status quo
center-left platform that is not what
millions of Americans want but it is
what the elites want it's what the DNC
it's what is really the underlying goal
here this all reinforces Joe Biden and
it's working very very well I know that
the David Pakman show audience is full
of curious and creative people who love
learning new things and bettering
themselves and that's why I'm so excited
to tell you about one of our sponsors
Skillshare the vibrant online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired
and it was great I got so much out of it
and hopefully you will see the fruits of
me taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it easier than
ever
Skillshare memberships are less than ten
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll